das ist wirklich ein sehr lustiges bild
und eine kleine wissenschaftliche
sensation ein dachs genau ein
nordamerikanischer silbersack witz
zufrieden in der gegend rum und das ist
nicht alles sondern dieser sachs hat
vorher wirklich unglaubliches geleistet
und das wurde zum ersten mal beobachten
wissenschaftler haben gefilmt wie er
eine ganze kuh verrät das video und sie
ist dazu kam jetzt bei klick zum ganzen
fix herzlich willkommen
davon arbeiten wenn man dass er sie
können ein vielfaches ihres
körpergewichtes schleppen aber dass ein
dachs eine ganze kuh verbundes das ist
den biologen der university of utah noch
nicht untergekommen die biologen trainer
und essen durch wollten eigentlich
andere art fresser wie berglöwen kojoten
oder geyer erforschen dafür legten die
sieben tote kühe aus und bauten kamera
fallen um zu dokumentieren wie
aasfresser sich an ihnen zu schaffen
machen aber eine der kühe verschwand
einfach zunächst vermutet wie die beiden
ein größeres tier hätte den kadaver
weggeschleppt aber es waren keine
schleifspuren versehen sondern es waren
scharf wurden die dort zu finden waren
und dann bot sich ihnen dieses bild als
sie die aufnahmen sichteten ein silber
sachs widmete sich dieser für ihn ja
eine herkules aufgabe dieses riesige
ungetüm vergraben fünf tage und nächte
machte der dax damit die kuh zu
beerdigen wobei das sind ja nicht ganz
aber dazu gleich mehr dabei bin ja
ziemlich planvoll und effektiv vor wie
man wie sie tag eine solch massive
aushöhlung ist für einen dax ziemlich
beeindruckend sagten fünf fehler
um diesen zu bekommen muss der dax eben
wer geschickt vorgeht
ja und eine beerdigung war es eben nicht
der silber sagt liegt so vorräte ab zum
einen will i know von konkurrenten
geschützt und zum anderen hat die erde
ja eine funktion wie ein kühlschrank die
erde ist in der peri nämlich deutlich
kühler als die umgebung so verhält sich
das weiß länger und der dax kann davon
wahrscheinlich wochen lang sehr für die
forscher war diese außergewöhnliche fund
wirklich etwas ganz besonderes
nicht nur dass der dax konnte er von
kleineren tieren wie vögeln oder
nagetieren lebt auch dass er ein so
großes tier überhaupt den angriff nimmt
und es dann auch noch wirklich
hinbekommt das hat die forscher schon
ziemlich verblüfft es gibt also das ist
für mich so ein bisschen die lehre
daraus tatsächlich noch eine menge auf
unserem planeten zu entdecken und das
auch noch direkt vor unserer nase oder
in diesem fall vor der kamera und wenn
ihr davon in zukunft nicht verpassen
wollt dann drückt man hier ein abo aufs
auge einfach klicken und gebt mir
natürlich gerne immer wieder einen auf
die glocke als rates gesang bleibt dran